Good afternoon.
Vinod Balachandran from Memorial Sloan Kettering Cancer Center in New York, and
I'll be chairing this session on cancer vaccines, the next immunotherapy
breakthrough.
So cancer immunotherapy has come a long way since the first
successful application of harnessing the immune system to fight cancer
by surgeon William Coley at Sloan Kettering now over a century ago.
And since then, many individuals, some highlighted here, have helped us discover
the molecules and cells through which the immune system
recognizes cancer, and in the modern era, develop
strategies to harness this to treat cancer patients either directly or indirectly.
But arguably, our last major discovery was now a decade ago,
leaving us all wondering what's next.
And a unifying theme that has really emerged from all of this work is that
T cells recognize genetic byproducts of
oncogenesis, neoantigens, to distinguish cancers as non-self.
And T cell recognition of neoantigens is a major driver of the
success of modern clinical immunotherapy, such as the checkpoints.
We know that tumors with more mutations respond
and those with fewer mutations do not.
So leading us to this question, if you can make T cells
directly against neoantigens, either in tumors with
few or many mutations, could you directly
generate clinical impact?
And in the past decade, we have seen significant progress towards this
across the mutational space
in cancers that are immunotherapy sensitive with many mutations, melanoma,
work by Uğur Sahin and Cathy Wu demonstrating that RNA and peptide vaccines can
make T cells against neoantigens.
And at the polar opposite of the immunological and mutational
spectrum in a cancer where immune therapy remains
ineffective and with few mutations, pancreatic cancer, our work
demonstrating that patients in fact make natural CD8 T cells against
neoantigens that are long-lived and may impact clinical outcome.
And since then, we now have multiple lines of evidence that there are many
paths
and platforms that can generate T cells against neoantigens.
But
does this lead to, in fact, clinical impact?
And in the past few years, we have some early evidence that this might be
the case.
In 2023, our work in a very small Phase I
non-randomized trial in pancreatic cancer, where we found adjuvant
unmodified RNA neoantigen vaccine response was associated with
delayed pancreatic cancer recurrence.
And the following year, in 2024, work by the late Jeffrey
Weber, stronger evidence in a Phase IIb randomized
study in resected high-risk melanoma where adjuvant
modified RNA neoantigen vaccines together with pembrolizumab
improves recurrence-free survival compared to pembrolizumab alone.
So
with this
early signs of clinical activity essentially spanning the mutational
spectrum, it puts the field at a critical inflection point
because what we really need now is broad-scale testing to close the gaps.
And it is exciting now to see lots of clinical trials ongoing
worldwide to test these concepts.
It is also exciting to see
we have the support of the federal government with the National Cancer Vaccine
Initiative, launched earlier this year by the National Cancer Institute and the
Foundation for National Institute of Health, to accelerate the development
and access of therapeutic cancer vaccines nationwide.
And this program is expected to launch in 2026.
So as we embark on the horizon of
cancer vaccines potentially being the next promising cancer
immunotherapy, several fundamental challenges now continue to exist across
all four pillars of cancer vaccinology as we head towards the next
generation of more effective cancer vaccines.
What is the optimal antigen? You heard a little bit about neoantigens today.
You'll hear about, do you even need a tumor antigen in cancers that are checkpoint
sensitive?
What is the optimal platform that can generate immunity with clinical impact?
Is it RNA? Is it peptide? Is it DNA? Perhaps all.
What is the optimal host that can generate
immunity?
Is it cancers with few to many mutations, early disease, advanced disease?
And finally, what are the optimal cells that you would need?
CD8 cells, CD4 cells, both. How do they behave in
tumors?
So we have a full stack ahead of you for today's session,
and each speaker will be followed by a short Q&A, and then we'll have time
for a short discussion at the end. And we'll begin with Cathy Wu.
Thanks for that introduction. We've got a lot to cover, so I'll jump right in if
the slides come up. And I want to thank Vinod and the organizers really
for this opportunity to share some of our recent unpublished
work. I'm a little bit nervous because I haven't presented this before,
but hopefully, you'll find it interesting.
I think I press here. Let's see.
Oh, it'll do it on its own?
Oh, I have to press start.
Okay.Here we go.
Okay, so this is just to remind ourselves, I think we're in an age of
immunotherapy. There's a lot of different immune modalities in there, but I
think the unique aspect about vaccines, it
is an opportunity to expand T cell responses
and promote immune surveillance and memory.
And I think that this modality, in particular, can amplify
pre-existing anti-tumor T cell responses, but also prime and
expand new anti-tumor T cell responses.
And before I get started, I just want to acknowledge my local brain
trust over in Boston. This has been
a long-term effort, initiated together with Nir
Hacohen, but also Ed Fritsch and Patrick Otten.
We've really been blessed to work in this wonderful environment to bring
together translational work together with fundamental biology and
advanced platforms. Vinod already told us about the
excitement that has been in place for over a decade now, ever
since next-generation sequencing has been available to us for
devising personalized strategies to identify
neoantigens. It starts with sequencing of DNA and RNA.
It integrates HLA typing and then prediction of
personalized HLA-binding peptides.
And at least for us,
from the very beginning, we
launched in a direction of synthetic long peptides because
there was already a plethora of FDA...
For the FDA agreement to go forward, there was already so much clinical
data of safety using long peptides.
Vinod already presented the incredible,
exciting time that we have had over the last seven
years, starting from 2017, when both peptide
and RNA-based approaches were first proof of concept, were tested in
melanoma,
all the way to where we are now, with Jeff Weber
presenting the clinical benefit of vaccine with a randomized, open-label
Phase II trial. And I'm really grateful
to
my colleagues and members of the speaking roster today for
participating in the Cancer Vaccines Roadmap.
There was broad representation across the country to bring
this effort together. Lots of Zoom calls through January and February, and we
are very excited to launch this national effort,
so more to come later in the spring.
But for today, I really want to focus on some recent work
that our group has been doing. We have studied a couple of
different cancers,
but
one area of focus, at least on the academic side, is to really
face challenges
that may or may not be taken up otherwise more broadly and really
think about these patients that are in need.
This audience knows very well that glioblastoma is rapidly fatal.
There are suboptimal responses to anti-PD-1 antibody
alone. This is very clear in this graphic
that's demonstrated on the right.
We know that there's low numbers of infiltrating T cells, and there have been
prior vaccine studies that have been undertaken with mixed
results, most recently in the past decade with
neoantigen targeting vaccines. And this is a real effort to
address glioblastoma on a personalized
nature and also to deal with tumor heterogeneity by
virtue of trying to target antigens that might
span the genetic diversity of
lesions that are present in these tumors.
And in the first effort that we reported back in
2019, this is the schema of what we did with our
peptide-based vaccines. Certainly, these are patients for standard of care.
They go through radiotherapy, and while they receive
radiotherapy, in the recovery time, it actually builds in a very
nice period of time to actually perform a vaccine
manufacture. The informatics, the sequencing, the informatics, and
then also the devising and identification of personal
somatic mutations for which to target, and then for the peptide
manufacture that we give together with poly-ICLC as a powerful
adjuvant. You can see that the schedule that we give is in
a prime boost manner, so high antigenic exposure
frequently up front, and then two boosts to stimulate immunologic memory.
More or less what we think is happening to mimic a viral infection.
And certainly from this very first effort, certainly this was feasible.
We were a small number of patients, but even then, we were
already able to pull out some interesting insights.
Number one, dexamethasone is bad.
So this is a way to flatline your immune
stimulation. Number two, those patients who didn't
get dexamethasone were actually able to mount circulating
T cell responses. Those are the red patient seven and eight
lines that you see. And
by immunohistochemistry, we could see a very nice
influx of T cells that were
present following vaccination. But we also could see
that
there was a lot of co-inhibitory receptors present on the
tumor-associated T cells, so much more work to do.
Now, for our trials, we do ascribe to the bench to bedside and
back again model. And performing these
investigator-initiated trials do afford us access to
tumor biopsy materials. So our team has really tried to
make an effort to learn more about the diseases that we are trying to go into,
and trying to treat our patients. And so in an effort
following our initial vaccine study, we worked very closely with
David Reardon, also with Keith Ligon and the fabulous
Dana-Farber
Brigham Cell Bank, tissue bank that we have for GBM.
And we asked, maybe let's start with
anti-PD-1, PD-L1 monotherapy.
Looking at 181 patients, and here you see in the purple, these are
newly diagnosed. Here are recurrent patients.
You can see over here their overall survival.
Most of these patients don't do well.
There are a few, a small percentage that actually have longer
overall survival, and we were able to perform
DNA and RNA sequencing.Again, very beholden
to a fabulous team of young people, including colleagues from the group
of Gaddy Getz and then Brian Urgulescu now at MD
Anderson. Again, we saw that dexamethasone at any time, whether at
start or within three months, is bad, so probably affecting the
priming of responses. TMB did not make a difference.
This has been reported by others, but again, we saw this in our data.
So if it's not the genetics and just like Vinod had presented, in a
lot of tumors, TMB does portend better response, not so in GBM.
Well, it turns out that it's transcriptional subtype that actually seems to
matter. And some of you may have heard the talks by Itai Terrosh
yesterday. There was also some talk about mesenchymal
phenotypes in the opening plenary yesterday.
In GBM, there are clear different transcriptional subtypes
that have been described. This mesenchymal subtype is interesting in
that it's associated with shorter survival after standard chemoradiation,
but it is also associated with greater T cell infiltration.
And these are the tumors that express higher HLA class I expression.
And when we looked in our group of patients, it was the mes phenotype
that actually did better. And there was a
relationship between degree of HLA class I expression.
And I think you can see really clearly here in magenta, here's HLA
class I and mesenchymal, lots of this
expression. In a non-mes, really not much of this
expression. And finally, we also saw a shift away from the mes transcriptional
programs as a mode of acquired resistance to ICB monotherapy.
So certainly persistent mes at recurrence is associated with better
ICB, but not for standard of care. So this is what
the so-called glass cohort, which is standard of care compared to
ICB.
There's a shift to the non-mes phenotype that's associated with
worse outcome in ICB, but better for standard of
care. And finally, because we had longitudinal samples, we could track
them genomically, and we could see in the presence of anti-PD-1
therapy that there was actually selection for
non-mes
genetic lesions over time. And so I think that's
actually been interesting to think about the tumor intrinsic
programs that impact
therapeutic response. Now, anti-PD-1, as many of you know,
has made a huge difference in our therapeutic landscape, but there have
been a number of publications in recent years that
impact how we think about it in relationship to immunotherapy.
So certainly, this is in the setting of a chronic viral
infection, and PD-1 pathway does seem to impact
long-term
generation of memory T cells. And also
anti-PD-1 blockade has been given in
advance of vaccine in preclinical models seem
to impact the efficacy of those vaccines.
So what does this mean right now for our patients who might be exposed to
anti-PD-1 therapy? And for
that reason, working together with David Reardon, and really Jack
Ganem working close in hand to analyze these results, we've launched
a clinical trial to actually test the timing
of anti-PD-1 therapy in relationship to vaccine.
So this is a four-cohort study. Initially, we thought about the
blue cohorts, so 1B, two, and three.
Here again, in the yellow, you see radiotherapy, here you see vaccine.
And we're varying
the administration of pembro. So 1B, I would say, is
what we've done before. For example, in our melanoma study, we
did have a patient who received vaccine and then pembro.
But what if patients got first the pembro and then the vaccine?
Or since radiotherapy also releases antigens, what if
we gave a slug of
pembro at the time of radiotherapy, let that wash out, go
in with a vaccine, and then come in with pembro thereafter?
So what could possibly happen with that?
So these are the cohorts. We've accrued close
to 40 patients with representation across the different cohorts.
You can see that based on RNA sequencing, we were able, from the
bulk data, to ascribe the dominant transcriptional
subtype. In terms of the vaccine, on average, we were able to
identify 10 targets to include in these
peptide-based vaccines. Some of those targets were
driver mutations that have been well-described.
In GBM, these were missense or frameshift mutations.
And we had some already interesting clinical results.
So we did actually, I forgot to mention... Sorry, going back.
Let's see if I can do that.
In the green, we also decided to add a 1A arm, and these
are patients with MGMT methylated.
And the difference here between 1A and 1B is one group
gets Temodar, so an alkylating reagent, which is
standard versus not. And so as we...
Okay, now I'm going backwards. Okay.
So
our first surprise was actually that the Temodar-treated
group actually did really quite well.
So their overall survival is well in excess of what is
the historic control. Temodar, we know,
generates lymphopenia. So we see that really clearly here, but these were
very nice results.
In terms of the three unmethylated
MGMT arms,
we actually saw only modest, rather similar overall survival
to standard of care. But even amongst these three groups,
we were surprised to see that cohort 1B, the one that
got pembro after vaccine, actually looked inferior to the
two that had pretreatment with pembro followed by
vaccine. So intriguing, something to think about.
So we tried to get a little bit under the hood and performed extensive immune
monitoring of the circulating immune response.
For sure, across the different cohorts, there were no differences in epitope
immunogenicity across the arms. And here you can see in the lavender,
these are de novo responses, and in the minority
were preexisting responses that were then amplified.
You can see per arm, there's a bit of variation to the extent
that
T cell responses were identified.
This was all performed using in vitro stimulated ELISpots.
We also had an internal control, which is, there was a tetanus peptide, so
we could-Confirm that each of these patients were able to mount
tetanus-specific responses equivalently.
Now, as we started to actually perform ex vivo ELISpot, so this is
really measuring what is the amplitude
of T cell responses against peptide pools
containing the vaccine peptides, we started to see a difference here.
So there were definitely
pool responses, and then there were those that were
not responsive. And as we started to dig into that a little bit more,
it was actually really the non-lyphopenic, so the
MGMT-unmethylated patients that were predominantly the
responders. And then when you started to look at the three different
cohorts, there was really no difference.
But amongst these patients, certainly,
the
degree to which there were ex vivo T cell responses made a
difference in terms of overall survival, and certainly with Cox regression
analysis adjusting for this and that and the other thing, it was the ex vivo T
cell responses that survived and seemed to be
predictive.
Now, how much of the T cells in the
blood
can be ascribed as vaccine-reactive?
For this, we actually ex vivo took PBMCs that were
post-vaccine. We put in the peptides, we let that expand
out for a few days, and then performed bulk TCR sequencing.
So then those that are expanded, those clonotypes by
TCR-seq, presumably are the ones that are vaccine-reactive.
And this gave us clonotypes to go after and track, and we could see
consistently across even up to two years that there are
persistence of those T cell responses for a good number of those
patients. It kind of peaks and kind of tracks out.
No difference amongst the cohorts.
And then we asked, well, what about within the tumor?
And here we had about 30-some tumors that we performed
single-nuclear sequencing. A bunch of these were pre, a
bunch were post, and then we also had longitudinal samples, and that's
kind of portrayed here, and they're distributed across the different
cohorts. And this is our ginormous UMAP.
But I think the key takeaway is that of those putative
vaccine-reactive clonotypes, again, consistent with our first study, we do
see expansion of those vaccine-reactive clonotypes following a
vaccine compared to pre at the
site of tumor. Since we had those clonotypes to
help identify those putative vaccine-reactive T cells, we could
also perform differential expression analysis between those that were
vaccine-reactive versus the TILs that were not.
And we do see some interesting phenotypes related to stemness and related
to T cell activation. And in terms of gene set enrichment
analysis, these were primarily, by the way, CD4 cells, and we see
activation signatures, progenitor exhausted in the TCR
signaling.
Now, one of the things that was interesting from the single-cell
data, once we break all those different cells
out, is that one of the differences between the methylated and the
unmethylated cohorts is you can see here that
in the temozolomide exposed cohort, you
actually see... Sorry, the unmethylated cohort, no TMZ,
you see increase in Tregs
following neoantigen vaccination.
And I think this could be related to a counterregulatory mechanism
in the face of immune selective pressure.
Interestingly enough, we do not see this in the
Temodor-exposed
cohort. And this is actually consistent with past
literature that has suggested that temozolomide depletes circulating
Tregs and promotes antigen-specific T cell responses to cancer
vaccines. This was primarily in pre-clinical models and using a model antigen.
And this stands in contrast to standard of care treatment therapy.
So this is data generated by the group of Mario Suva, and
we see in the setting of standard therapy,
chemotherapy, we don't see this
Treg upregulation at time of recurrence.
And then hearkening back to our anti-PD-1 work,
again, in this group of vaccinated patients, we do see that
it is the MES-like hypoxia-related
phenotype that is associated with better response.
So we see that again.
So for this part of the talk, I would just say that lots of
interesting insights that we're beginning to see.
This is still a work in progress, but the overall survival is promising,
especially in those receiving temozolomide.
It does generate lymphopenia, but it does modify the immune microenvironment with
decreased Tregs after vaccination.
We do see that the neoantigens that we selected for vaccine are immunogenic,
with mounting circulating immune responses to the vaccine.
The strength of the circulating response and the breadth of the response seems to
be associated with improved survival, something that we are hearing thematically
over and over again across different vaccine studies.
The
malignant cells are associated with survival, those that are immunogenic.
So this MES phenotype seems to fall out.
And the vaccine-reactive clonotypes are detectable in post-treatment
tumors. The impact of timing of anti-PD-1 relative to
ongoing vaccination is ongoing. Am I already past my time?
One minute.
Okay. So in the last minute and a half, I'll just
show off some of our new capabilities, because we are always interested
in trying to improve what we can glean from
our patient samples. And here, like others, we are
digging into spatial. We've had really the benefit of working
closely with the Fei Chen Lab at the Broad Institute and really trying to
dig in
to find out the localization of these T cell clonotypes of
interest.
We've, for some time now, been working on trying to genotype spatially
defined transcriptomes to study tumor TME interactions,
because we are interested in mutations that define neoantigens, and on
the other side, we're interested in TCRs that also have
sequence-defined barcodes that define them.
And so,
the methodology, you'll have to wait for the paper to
check it out, but in general, it is genotyping using long-read sequencing
in the Nanoranger-...
a workflow that is piled on top of slide tags.
And this is an example of a RCC patient sample where you
can see that they're right here in the red.
These are TCRs that we know are
specific for a neoantigen, NSUN5, that we had
defined. And then you can also see that there are,
in the blue,
NSUN-specific T cells that are in the vicinity, so
suggesting this co-localization of the T cell together
with the antigen.
We're short on time, but only to say that we are finding so many interesting
interactions as we dig into this, including the spatial
co-localization, the signatures that are present, the evidence of
expansion,
differences regionally of T cell avidity, and we've been
able to expand this capability into a larger number of tumors that
allow us to not only look at
the TCRs that are interesting in those
tumors and in relationship to the mutations that we are
profiling per tumor. So I'll stop there and just say that
exciting times. Vaccines are a promising modality.
We hope that it is, for these cold tumors, a way and a modality to warm
the microenvironment. We got to do, collectively as a
community, better at understanding the TME.
I think that is actually very important for how we devise our vaccine
therapies. Some of our work that I hope I've convinced you that the tumor
intrinsic aspects can potentially identify
predictive features for response to immunotherapy, and we are super excited about
multi-omics spatial characterization
of the tissues. Thank you.
Thank you, Cathy, for that. We have time for a few questions.
So I could get started. So the CD4 T cells that you're inducing with the
peptide vaccines in the tumor,
can you tell us a little bit more about what they look like?
Do you see them still circulating in the periphery as well as infiltrating the
tumor?
Yeah. So,
yes.
They are definitely present. Of course, this is interesting because we're
predicting on CD8, and yet what we're seeing really
expand, at least in the circulation, are CD4s.
We do see CD8s that are coming up within the tumor, but
predominantly it is still CD4. It may be related to the modality
of our approach with peptide vaccines, where
maybe the activation energy
to stimulate a CD4 response is lower when you give free
peptide than maybe CD8. Maybe we need actually better professional
antigen-presenting cells to be present at the time of priming to
really launch that CD8 positive response.
Maybe keep talking, and it'll turn on.
Yeah. So, great talk.
I was wondering, is there any evidence that the
vaccine-induced T cells may be resistant to the effect of Temodar?
I thought that data was really, really
cool.
Yeah. I presented
to you everything we know right now.
We are digging very deeply into this, and I think it
is curious. Temodar is standard of care for
MGMT
methylated tumors. The great survival that we're seeing,
it makes you wonder maybe we should even give it for patients with
unmethylated tumors just for the immune modulatory
microenvironment reprogramming effects.
But
we're still trying to sort that out.
Thanks.
Hi. I just had a quick question about the difference between
CD4+ and CD8+ T
cells in immunotherapy. Which would you
say is the biggest priority in targeting, and what
are the different ways that you address those separately?
I also had another question regarding how would you address tumor
heterogeneity in immunotherapies?
Yeah. So I'll answer this second question first.
So our personalized vaccines from the
get-go, even back in 2017, were
designed to specifically address tumor heterogeneity. Why?
Because there's personalized. Second, because we're not going after one
target, we're not going after two targets.
At least in melanoma, we're typically targeting up to
20 different targets. In GBM, it's harder, lower
mutation burden, more typically 10, but a range of
8 to 14, 15.
If you look at the mRNA studies that are out there, they're targeting 34
different epitopes, and many other studies out there are
going with
higher numbers. But I think the whole point of that is
actually to head-on address the question of tumor
heterogeneity. In terms of the targets, when we select our
targets to include in the vaccine, it is driven a lot by
the HLA binding score, based on our predictive
algorithms. We also look at the expression of the
mutated genes that we're targeting to ensure that those
targets are expressed in the tumor.
We can do one more short question.
Great talk. So
if you only look at shared antigens, so you did have some
shared neoantigen in your pool of peptides.
If you only look at those responses, do you see any correlation
with survival, not as a pool response?
So for clarification, these were all personal targets.
We had zero shared amongst-
I mean, sorry, driver mutation
Even amongst the drivers, they were very individualized.
So if the drivers were recurrent,
I'm almost certain they're not the same mutation, same
peptide sequence because of HLA restrictions from
one patient to the other.
So you do see the correlation?
I'm happy to talk to you more about it later.
Thank you.
Thank you, Kathy.
So for our next talk, we have our next generation star, Adam
Griffin from MD Anderson, who will talk about mechanisms by
which mRNA vaccines augment response to immune checkpoint blockade.
Okay, excellent. Well, thank you so much for the opportunity to present this work
on behalf of my colleagues.
Today, I'm going to talk about mRNA vaccines and their ability to stimulate
anti-tumor responses.
Speak up.
Okay. Can you all hear me okay? All right.
Let's see. So,
the setting that I want to focus on today is immune checkpoint blockade, which has
really revolutionized the way we treat cancer, but remains ineffective in a
subset of patients who lack preexisting anti-tumor immune responses.
And one of the goals of personalized RNA nanoparticle vaccines is
to provide this anti-tumor immunity in the patients who lack it at baseline.
And there's been a lot of investigation in cancer vaccines in general, and
particularly in the mRNA vaccine space over the last few years, with significant
attention from both industry and the academic world.
And a lot of this cancer vaccine work has
been led by those on the panel with me.
So I'm really honored to be here today to talk a little bit about what we're doing
in this space.
Overall, there's over 100 clinical trials now investigating these
personalized RNA therapeutics, and that's not even to mention the DNA and
peptide vaccines that are being evaluated.
And this is how I got my start in cancer immunotherapy.
We started working on a personalized RNA nanoparticle vaccine to treat patients
with brain tumors.
I'm showing data from a vaccine that we generated at the University of
Florida. I was really fortunate to start working with this vaccine in mouse models.
We ran a canine trial. I'm showing our first canine patient here, and
these dogs did very well on vaccine.
And now we've been able to launch a Phase 1 clinical study in patients with GBM
that's currently ongoing, and we've treated about a half dozen patients, with the
systemic RNA nanoparticle approach.
But while developing these personalized vaccines, we realized a few of the
complications of a personalized RNA nanoparticle vaccine approach.
The first is the time that it takes to actually manufacture these vaccines.
On the RNA side, we're talking about four to eight weeks for manufacturing.
On the peptide side, it's a little longer, maybe 26 weeks, to actually
produce these vaccines. And that really relegates these vaccines to the
adjuvant setting,
which is a delay from when the patients are diagnosed.
The other major limitation is the cost of these personalized
therapeutics. Obviously, if we're personalizing a vaccine for each individual
patient, we're not able to manufacture these things in bulk, and so the cost of
these therapeutics is significantly higher than if we could manufacture an
off-the-shelf therapeutic. And then the final note about
personalized vaccines, and really where I'm going to spend the bulk of my time
today, is on the complexity of these vaccines.
When we write grants and we write papers about these RNA vaccines, we like to
propose this very linear story, where we are able to select
targets from a tumor. We prescribe what the immune system should
target, and we inject our RNA vaccine, and if we generate T cells
reactive against those targets, we have this clear line to tumor regression.
But in reality, I think that the reality here is a little more complex
than what we like to portray. I'm going to show one experiment that kind of
highlights this, and this is an experiment we ran in 2016.
Again, at the time, we were developing a personalized vaccine, and our goal here
was to show how important it was to personalize the vaccine.
And so we used a metastatic model of osteosarcoma that
was uniformly fatal in our mouse models, and we compared the
personalized RNA vaccine here, labeled K7M2 in blue,
to a GFP vaccine coding for green fluorescent protein, so
nothing to do with the cancer. And what we initially wrote in the paper about
this was that clearly personalization is important because the blue line is better
than the gray line. But what I think is a much more interesting conclusion is
what if we didn't have the blue line?
Then our conclusion would have been that a GFP RNA nanoparticle
vaccine doubles survival in an aggressive metastatic
model of osteosarcoma. And I think that this is a much more interesting
conclusion because this raises the possibility that we could generate a
universal RNA therapeutic that we could use to prime the immune response in a
large number of patients without knowing anything about the antigens that are
specifically present in their tumor.
And so we've been tracking this story down, and we published it last year in
"Nature Biomedical Engineering" with the idea that we could use a systemic RNA
nanoparticle vaccine to really prime immune responses without
knowing anything about the tumor antigens.
Along the way, though,
the world changed, and we were presented with a really unique
opportunity, because 3.4 billion doses of an mRNA
vaccine were administered to target a non-tumor antigen.
I'm talking about the COVID vaccine, which is targeting the spike protein
in the COVID virus.
And so what we wanted to test was whether the COVID mRNA
vaccine could also be used to prime anti-tumor immune responses, and
maybe sensitize tumors to immune therapy.So to answer this question,
we looked back at patients treated with immune therapy at MD Anderson.
I'm showing first data with patients with lung cancer who happened to receive a
COVID vaccine around the time they initiated immune therapy.
Here we're looking at a 100-day window before or after they initiated ICI,
and we found this really striking result, which was that those patients who
happened to receive the vaccine had significantly improved overall survival
relative to patients who didn't receive a COVID mRNA vaccine.
This was true for patients with stage III and IV non-small cell lung cancer, and it
was really specific to this one context of an mRNA vaccine
plus ICI. This didn't work in patients who received chemotherapy.
They didn't seem to benefit from the vaccine, and it also didn't work for other
vaccines like influenza or pneumonia vaccines, where we saw no benefit
of vaccination in timing with ICI.
We also replicated this finding in patients with stage IV melanoma.
Here I'm showing a propensity-matched cohort of patients with stage IV melanoma
with overall survival on the left and progression-free survival on the right, which
really showed the strong signal of a relationship between the timing of
these two therapeutics.
Now, I want to acknowledge, though, this data was published in October, but it was
really designed as a signal-finding analysis, and there were some limitations to
our initial study. One is this allowed for a healthy vaccinee
bias because we were comparing vaccinated patients against unvaccinated
patients. There were also relatively small cohorts here.
And we also had a problem with immortal time bias because we allowed vaccination
after receipt of ICI. And although we tried to control for this statistically, it's
a very difficult thing to really tease out what the effect of that immortal time
bias is. And finally, there were also some error effects in here that the patients
who got vaccine in 2021 were being compared against patients who
didn't have the opportunity to get vaccine in 2020, or may be less likely to get
the vaccine in 2022 or 2023. And so to address some of
these problems, we went to our biostatisticians and we said, "How can we design
the most robust possible analysis to really
determine whether there's a signal here to follow?" And so what they came up with
was a target trial emulation, where we essentially pre-specify if we were going to
have run a clinical trial, what that trial would look like, and then we apply that
to our historical cohort. In this setting, we did a pan-tumor
analysis, so we enrolled all patients at MD Anderson who had
received immune checkpoint blockade in a two-year
period. And then we only looked at those patients in our group of
interest, only patients who received the vaccine before they got ICI.
So we eliminated the immortal time bias problem with this analysis.
And then we used statistical techniques, including inverse probability weighting,
to really adjust for the other variables between the groups.
And what we found was that after we really carefully controlled for as many
variables as possible, this relationship stood very strong, and those patients who
happened to receive the vaccine within 30 days prior to
receiving immune therapy lived significantly longer than those who didn't across
this pan-tumor cohort. We also found that this relationship persisted
in different eras. So in 2021, when the vaccine use was very prevalent,
we saw a strong relationship. And also in 2022, when the vaccines
were less
widely utilized, we still saw a strong relationship with
survival.
We also, to cover our bases, wanted to make sure that this wasn't an MD Anderson
specific effect, and so we've now replicated this analysis with our colleague
Jake New, who's at Scripps Health.
And he was able to find the same effects with the COVID mRNA vaccine, boosting
responses to immune checkpoint blockade in our retrospective studies.
And similar to our cohorts, he didn't see effects for other
vaccines like influenza. But all this retrospective data we really have to
take with a grain of salt. And so we took these findings to the lab to see if we
could replicate them. We essentially made a version of the BioNTech
COVID mRNA vaccine that's available at CVS following their published
specifications, and we used it as a therapeutic in our mouse models.
And here I'm showing data from two established tumor models, melanoma
B16-F0 on the left and then a Lewis lung carcinoma model of
non-small cell lung cancer on the right.
In both settings, we waited until the tumors were large, at least 100 millimeters
cubed, and then we had started administering ICI with or without a COVID
vaccine intramuscularly. And really strikingly, we found that this
intramuscular COVID vaccine was able to sensitize these tumors to immune checkpoint
blockade.
So in thinking about how this was happening, we thought back to the way that we had
designed our personalized vaccine.
And with our personalized RNA vaccine, we found that it was a potent
activator of the innate immune response.
After we gave this vaccine, 24 hours later, we activated essentially every myeloid
cell in the body. We were looking in the liver, the spleen, the lung,
the tumor, the lymph nodes. Everywhere we looked, we would see dendritic cells and
macrophages that were strongly activated after receipt of this vaccine.
Now, we didn't know if we would see the same thing with the COVID vaccine, and the
reason is the COVID vaccine was specifically designed not to produce
a strong interferon alpha burst. So if you'll recall, in
2023, the Nobel Prize was awarded for the discovery that we could
use N1-methylpseudouridine to silence toll-like receptor 7 activation and
allow mRNA to be safer to use in humans.
It also increases the translation efficiency of that messenger RNA, and that
technology is incorporated into the COVID vaccine.
So we weren't sure if we'd be able to see the same increase in interferon alpha and
myeloid activation with the COVID mRNA vaccine that was available.
So we first started with a panel of cytokines to see what was happening in our
mouse models. But in the mice, the number one most
upregulated cytokine after receipt of this vaccine was actually interferon alpha.
And so what we think is happening here is that although the N1-methylpseudouridine
modification is very effective at minimizing TLR7 activation,
there's a backdoor activation pathway,
where mRNA, when it's combined with a lipid nanoparticle, actually triggers a
second intracellular receptor called MDA5, and that receptor is
responsible for the surge in interferon alpha that we're seeing in our mouse
models. We think the reason this happens is that when you combine the
RNA with a lipid nanoparticle, you actually form higher molecular weight
structures that we think are activating MDA5.
We have a little more work to do there to really tease that story out, but that's
where our current thoughts are and how we're getting this
production.So the next question, we're seeing interferon alpha production.
We next wanted to know, is it important?
And so we went back to our mouse models and we knocked it out, and we found that
when you block interferon alpha, you totally abrogate the benefit of the COVID
vaccine. So it seems that the mRNA vaccine's effects are really mediated
by this surge in interferon alpha.
So to see what the alpha was doing throughout the body, we looked at the tumor and
the spleen of these mice and found in both places that there was a significant
myeloid activation that occurred 24 hours after receipt of this vaccine.
Here I'm showing dendritic cells and macrophages from the tumor, but you see the
same thing in the spleen. And then in the tumor-draining lymph nodes, not only did
these cells become activated, but they started picking up tumor antigen and
presenting them to T cells, priming anti-tumor T cell responses.
Here I'm showing tumor-reactive T cells targeting
six tumor-associated antigens that were relevant in our model of B16-F0.
And you can see in every case, the mice who received the COVID vaccine and PD-1
blockade had increased numbers of these tumor-reactive T cells in their spleens.
Not only did they expand these cells in lymphoid organs, but those T cells were
actually able to infiltrate into tumors where we found them in much higher numbers.
And then
we found they accumulated in tumors.
And when they did that, they started recognizing tumor antigen and
secreting interferon gamma. And the tumor cells responded by increasing
PD-L1 expression on their surface, presumably to turn off this
T cell attack.
And so when you combine this therapy with
immune checkpoint blockade, we think this is why you're able to mediate this tumor
regression. We generate T cells in the periphery, they get to the tumor, and then
we can block the compensatory response with PD-1 blockade.
So this is all very nice in mouse models, but we wanted to prove this in humans as
well to make sure that the same
mechanisms were operant here. And so this is a study we did with healthy
volunteers at MD Anderson. I'm the guy in blue, and there's a lot of my lab mates
and friends behind me. We basically gave ourselves the COVID vaccine at CVS all at
the same time, and then got our blood drawn at different time points.
And then we used the NeuLISA Seq platform to look at 250
different cytokines, really sensitively to see what the mRNA vaccine was
doing across the cytokine profile, because we believe that this is a
cytokine-driven effect. And again, we weren't sure if we would see interferon alpha
because of the modifications to the RNA.
But across this 250 cytokine panel, we saw 37 cytokines that were
upregulated after the vaccine, after controlling for multiple comparisons testing.
And the number one most upregulated cytokine, just like in the mice, was
interferon alpha. And it wasn't a subtle increase.
It went at least 86-fold increase from baseline in our least responding patient,
up to 865-fold in our strongest responder.
And this interferon alpha had significant effects on the myeloid compartment.
So we ran flow cytometry on our blood and found that the myeloid cells, the
11B and 11C positive cells, became activated.
We also saw activation of natural killer cells and CD8 T cells in the
periphery.
So we're seeing similar effects initially to the vaccine.
Now, in humans, it's very difficult to tease out tumor-reactive T cells in a
prospective trial, but it's even harder in the retrospective setting.
And so as a surrogate marker for the production of tumor-reactive T cells,
we looked at the PD-L1 expression on the tumors with the hypothesis that if
we generated tumor-reactive T cells in our patients, their tumor cells would
respond by increasing PD-L1 expression.
And so we
assembled a large cohort of patients with non-small cell lung cancer who had had
biopsies at our institution, and we then
separated them into groups based on whether they received the vaccine before
biopsy or not. And really interestingly, we found that those patients who happened
to receive a COVID vaccine within 100 days prior to their biopsy, they actually
had higher PD-L1 expression on their tumors.
It was 30% higher in this group relative to baseline.
And as clinicians, we're really focused on these thresholds that guide our
treatment decision making. So we think about the threshold of 50% guiding
whether a patient might be able to be treated with monotherapy, with immune
checkpoint blockade, or whether they would need chemotherapy as well.
And so really importantly, there was a 20% increase in the likelihood that these
patients would be in this
group of more likely to respond to immune therapy of greater than
50% PD-L1 expression. So it's possible that these vaccines may have actually
changed the way these patients were treated.
So we think this is a clinically important finding because it may have
modified how these patients were managed. And then that was in lung cancer.
But we've also looked across other tumors in a larger cohort and found the same
effect, that with even a pan-tumor cohort, those patients who
happened to get the vaccine prior to biopsy had significantly higher PD-L1
expression on their tumors, signifying to us that they may have generated
anti-tumor immunity.
So in summary, we think that our data really supports a model in which if your T
cells can't see an immunologically cold tumor, and we can provide an RNA vaccine,
and even if that RNA vaccine doesn't code for a tumor antigen, the
interferon alpha that's produced from that RNA vaccine travels systemically and
can activate immune cells throughout the body, particularly in the tumor.
And those tumor-reactive
innate immune cells can then prime anti-tumor T cell responses.
When those T cells enter the tumor microenvironment, they secrete interferon gamma,
and there's a compensatory increase in PD-L1 expression on the tumor cells.
And ultimately, we're hopeful that this combination with immune checkpoint blockade
can overcome that PD-L1 expression and mediate improved survival.
Our next step here, we've shown impressive results with the COVID vaccine, and so
we really want to test this in the prospective setting.
And so we've designed a pragmatic Phase II/III clinical trial to really test
whether we should be using these things in clinic.
We have about a dozen sites who are signed on.
This trial is being led by the University of Florida and MD Anderson Cancer Center.
And we'd absolutely love to chat with anyone here about any ideas that you have
about ways that we could design this effectively and get this into patients quickly
and any partners who would be interested in participating with us.
And then the last note that I'll make before I close is
the COVID vaccine, we've shown really impressive results with it, but it
wasn't designed to do this, and actually it was kind of designed not to do this.
And so we think we have a large ramp of opportunity to
dial this type of an effect up and increase the
sensitivity to these RNA vaccines.
And so we've started playing with the technology in our lab to see if we can
optimize RNA therapeutics, specifically as immune adjuvants to immune checkpoint
blockade. I'm showing data from our first modification, which doubled the
anti-tumor effect, and we're hopeful that we can build on this
more.Ultimately,
my hope for the future is that we could have an mRNA vaccine that would be
available off the shelf that we could administer to patients to prime anti-tumor
immune responses. And then, of course, we'd love to follow this with a personalized
vaccine, as soon as that vaccine was manufactured and available.
I'm hopeful that the unification of these two approaches can really
move the needle for our patients. So in summary, we've shown that these widely
available COVID mRNA vaccines may sensitize tumors to immune checkpoint
blockade. Clinical trials to evaluate these effects are being planned, and
we hope to open soon. And we're hopeful that these findings may inform
development of even more effective universal immune modifying agents
that we can use off the shelf for our patients.
So with that, I'd like to thank the huge team at MD Anderson, University of
Florida, and Scripps, who contributed to this work, and our funders and the
patients whose data we used to make these conclusions.
So thank you all so much for your time. Really appreciate it.
We have time for one question, as we're running behind a bit.
Great talk. Quick question. Have you tried adding,
within your mRNA vaccine, as a
control, a sequence that encodes for one new
antigen and try to distinguish whether there's an added benefit
in there?
Yeah. In our mouse models, a personalized vaccine is always better than a
non-personalized vaccine. That's why I think the use case of these
vaccines is going to be in the setting where you haven't identified the neoantigens
yet. But we have a lot to learn about when you should use a
universal or when you should use a personalized vaccine approach.
Okay. Thank you
for that, and we'll move on to the next speaker.
We have Robert Seder from the Vaccine Research Center at the NIH.
Thanks very much, Vinod, for inviting me, and this is an honor to
be with my fellow panelists.
I'm at the NIH, so I have no disclosures.
I wish I had some disclosures, but
for now, there's none. So today, I'll talk about four things, and I'm going to pick
up on things that Cathy and Adam talked about, is first is
we developed a neoantigen peptide vaccine platform several
years ago, and I'm going to show you some potential improvements that might be
able to
be made with peptide-based vaccines.
Second of all, I'm going to
introduce you to a concept where you give therapeutic vaccination
and you get T cell expansion, and then you get innate immunity
through type one interferon, exactly what Adam just showed you in the tumor
microenvironment, called VACCINATE.
Third, I'm going to show you some new data on a comprehensive approach
for adoptive cell therapy using vaccination.
And at the end, I'll give you a little bit of data on some spatial transcriptomic
analysis following ACT and vaccination.
So when we started this,
close to 10 years ago, this was an original paper by Lelia Delamar
at Genentech, and they were studying peptide
responses. And this was at the beginning of the field, and so you were using
synthetic long peptides and giving them with poly IC.
And I think the early clinical data showed, and I think Cathy mentioned this today,
that most of the responses were CD4 responses.
So even though you're using long peptides designed on class
one, you're getting CD4 responses.
So obviously, you want to get better CD8 responses and better
cross priming. Two is when you have long peptides, and
person who did this in my lab, Jeff Lynn, was a chemist, is there's things
called hydropathy. This is a hydropathy plot where if you take a
series of, say, 500 peptides, you can see that some are
hydrophilic, some are kind of intermediate, and then some are hydrophobic.
The hydrophobic peptides are difficult because you can't get them in solution, or
they become particulate, which makes it difficult as a product.
So you want to solve two things. You want to get every peptide to solution,
because breadth is important, and you want to get better cross priming.
So just what Jeff had developed is he was able to take a
charged peptide moiety and essentially get any
peptide in solution. Then he put a cathepsin cleavable linker,
so when it got into a cell, it would get broken up.
And then he attached it to a hydrophobic
polymer linked to a Toll 7/8 agonist.
So we chose Toll 7/8 because Toll 7 stimulates
plasmacytoid dendritic cells to secrete type one interferon,
and Toll 8 stimulates all other dendritic cell subsets to secrete
IL-12. So you would cover activation of all
APCs. And when you link those together, you get a 50
nanometer nanoparticle, and that would get taken up by dendritic
cells. And so working with Lelia and the group at Genentech,
they had taken the MC38 tumor, and they actually
eluted peptides. So this was not predicted.
They knew the peptides were in class one, and these were the peptides on the
x-axis, and they gave those peptides with poly IC and
anti-CD40, a potent
adjuvant combination. And you can see that only two of the peptides,
Reps1 and ADGBK in their hands, induce CD8
responses. When we put it in our platform, you can see now with
the nanoparticle, all of the antigens were responsive
and the magnitude was higher. So I think this showed us, and then
I'm going to show you some data on protection.
This clearly shows you that this platform might be optimized for both
magnitude and breadthSo then our first therapeutic
experiment is we gave the vaccine, we established this
MC38, which is a colon carcinoma. We gave it at day seven, and then at
day seven and 14, we gave the vaccine, either
subcu or IV. And at
day 14, they were given
anti-PD-L1. And so you can see when we gave these
different doses, subcu or IV, we had the exact same
magnitude, really potent CD8 responses to this
one epitope. And then when we look at the tumor curves, here is the
unvaccinated tumors. They grow out quickly.
So remarkably, despite those high frequency of CD8
cells, when they got subcu twice, there was no
protection. When we gave the IV group, you can see there's really
good control. And when you gave the IV group without the
antigen, so it would just be innate stimulation, there was no
effect. So the summary of this is that IV was
required. You had antigen and innate stimulation, and what was a bit puzzling is
why weren't those high frequency of CD8 cells by the
subcu working?
And so the question is: What were the mechanisms by which IV vaccination
was working? So
we did RNA seq on the T cells seven days
post boost, and you can see here's a UMAP of both the IV and the
subcu, and what you'll notice is there's a population in the
IV which has these canonical stem-like genes, like
TCF7 and SLAMF6. So this makes
sense that that was a protective vaccine.
You induce stem-like cells, and they required
anti-PD-L1 for its effect. By contrast, when we gave the
subcu immunizations, you got this high frequency of effector
cells that were notable for granzyme and KLRG1.
So this told us that we could control the magnitude and
importantly, the quality of the response just based on the
difference of how we gave the vaccine.
And I think this highlights what's a major theme in the field is that
stem-like CD8 cells are going to be better for protection against
tumors.
Okay, so let's just summarize what I just told you.
So the question is: Does IV vaccination do anything else?
And so you might imagine, since it was connected to a Toll 7-8
agonist, when we looked at type I interferon in the serum
following IV, you can see there's a rapid spike.
This is exactly what Adam just showed you.
When you gave RNA, you got a rapid spike of type I interferon.
I'm not going to show you the other cytokines, but the subcu did not give you
any innate stimulation. And so the question is: Is now
the IV not only gave you better quality cells, but you have
systemic type I interferon, and does this have an
effect in the tumor microenvironment?
So we looked in the tumor microenvironment 24 hours after the
vaccination, and here are the UMAPs from the untreated animals that
did poorly, the subcu animals that were vaccinated that
did poorly, and the IV animals. And you'll notice that there's one
population amongst all these different antigen-presenting cell
subsets that is gone. And that population
happens to be a specific monocyte subset that
contains a gene called CHIL3. And so
it turns out that reduction in this population is
specific to IV, and it's dependent on type I interferon.
So again, similar to what Adam showed you, had we took
IV and we depleted type I interferon during the vaccine
process, it abrogated protection, and this
population came back up. So this tells you that the
type I interferon was modulating the tumor microenvironment, and
specifically, I'm just going to show you this one bad actor of
this monocyte subset.
Okay. So now to summarize, this is the first part of the talk,
is this paradigm called vaccinate, where you have,
I showed you that antigen-specific CD8 cells are
necessary, but might not be sufficient.
You had all those effector cells with the subcu, but they didn't work, and
IV gave you those stem-like cells.
The vaccination generates or boosts CD8 cells, and the
stem-like cells are optimal for protection.
And then the innate part came from the IV route, where you got
type I interferon.
So before I knew Adam was preceding me,
but I had highlighted that I think the data go well together as
a package.
Okay, so now we're going to get into indications for tumor vaccines
and adoptive cell therapy based on the extent of disease.
And so in the adjuvant therapy, you're going to see an incredible
presentation by Binod, and they talked about the data by Jeff Weber,
and certainly in melanoma and in pancreatic
cancer, in the adjuvant setting, where
there's really low to undetectable tumor burden,
less potential tumor heterogeneity, and less suppressive tumor
microenvironment,
an effective vaccine might work quite well.
I think this differs from when you have bulky
metastatic disease, where you would have higher
tumor burden, more heterogeneity, and more
suppressive TME. So there, do you need, if magnitude counts
and quality counts, what are you going to do for that?
And so there, I think you have to consider, would you use adoptive
cell therapy, and then would you need adoptive cell therapy with a
vaccine?
So if you go back to really, so I've been at the NIH for
close to 35 years, and
Steve Rosenberg's been there the entire time, and so I go to his lecture every
year. This is data where he was doing this back 35
years ago, and this is someone with melanoma that he gave adoptive cell
therapy with TILs, and you had these dramatic effects.
So we know that adoptive cell therapy against melanoma,
which has a high number of neoantigen, is a very susceptible tumor to
immune therapy. TIL therapy can work well, and in fact, it's
approved for that.What's a bigger issue
is their success with adoptive cell therapy with
TILs for other metastatic epithelial tumors.
So right now, Stephanie Goff, Frank Lowy, and Steve have a large
cohort of GI tumors, and their most recent publication
shows that TIL therapy can give them about a 20%
response rate. So the question is how to improve
ACT against these very difficult advanced
tumors.
And so we looked at this holistically.
So this is kind of the standard of care for ACT.
You would take out a tumor,
cut it into bits, put it into culture.
They get IL-2 for two weeks, and then they get anti-CD3 and
anti-CD28 for another couple of weeks.
So they've been stimulated for a month, and at the end of a month, you
get billions of cells, and they end up transferring 10 to the
ninth or 10 to the 10th cells. So those of us who have done
in vitro T cell biology will realize when you culture cells for a
month, they can be effector-like or exhausted.
So one idea is, during the expansion phase, can you
do something that will expand them so you have magnitude,
but alter them so you have favorable quality?
Or can you maintain the stem-like characteristics?
So you remember in
people's tumors, they're going to be very heterogeneous, and so it
might not be a one-size-fits-all, but that's the idea, is
magnitude and quality. The second thing is once you put them in,
the standard of care is they get pre-treated, and then they get given
IL-2. Rather than that, can you just give them a
vaccine to expand the T cells, and again, go back to
what I originally showed you, is have a vaccine that would alter the tumor
microenvironment? So that's what I'm going to show you.
So this is just a T cell signaling pathway, and
the broad
message here is through T cell activation, you either
get proliferation kind of at the expense of differentiation.
So you can see stemness is on the right with TCF1 at the bottom, and
proliferation's on the left. So what we're using, and this has been
described by Crystal Paulus several years ago, is a PI3
kinase delta inhibitor. And magically what that does is it
allows the T cells during the culture to expand, but also it
limits their differentiation so you can retain some stemness.
So that's exactly what we did. So we started out with a very reductionist
mouse system. So we used, and this is OVA.
I can tell you we've done this with GP100, and we're doing this now with
TIL cells, but this is just to make proof of principle.
And so we start with OT-1, and we either culture them for four days
with polyclonal stimulus, anti-CD3, CD28, IL-2,
or we add in that PI3 kinase inhibitor.
And at the end of four days, you can see we have two very distinct populations.
One up top are PD-1 positive
and mostly TCF1 negative. So they're enriched in
effectors. And the one on the bottom are 80%
PD-1 positive, TCF1 positive. Those are the
cells that can self-renew. Those are the cells that can become
effectors and respond to anti-PD-1.
So we have two distinct populations we can study to see how
they do for adoptive cell therapy.
Expansion was similar to both. So we achieved both magnitude
and a difference in quality. This is just a volcano plot
of the single-cell analysis of these populations.
So you can see in the stem cell-like pool, you have the canonical
genes of Slamf6 and Tcf7 as well as their
CCR7 positive and cell is
CD62L. So they're favorable phenotype, they look
like stem-like cells, whereas on the other side, you can see EMS and
granzyme B and interferon gamma. So those are effector cells.
So what we did is we took those cells, so they're labeled with a congenic
marker, and then we took naive
mice, and we gave them B16 expressing the antigen, and we
waited 12 days. And so the tumors got quite large, and then we
gave them the cells, either the effector or the stem-like cells, and then three
days later, we gave them the vaccine.
And so you can see that with no therapy, the cells grow out.
The vaccine alone doesn't do anything. That's the open triangles.
And then you can see the cells alone, the effector-like cells, the
open magenta circles or the closed.
The effector-like cells with and without the vaccine have some effect,
better than nothing.
Here's the stem-like cells alone, and here's the stem-like cells plus
vaccination. So this clearly shows that the types of cells matter.
Stem-like cells are better than effector-like cells, and they need
vaccine. When you look at survival, the ones that survive are all
the ones that got stem-like cells and vaccine.
And then when you look at the expansion of the antigen-specific
CD8 response that make interferon gamma, it's the one on the far
right, which are the stem-like cells in the vaccine.
I would note that we did not pre-condition it.
We didn't radiate these animals or give them IL-2.
And if this were to work,
the potential advantages, could a vaccine be much more better
tolerated than giving the pre-conditioning and the IL-2?
Okay, so now this is similar to what Adam showed you.
Now let's look at what's happening in the blood following transfer of the
cells and the vaccination. So you can see the vaccine alone does
give you some interferon alpha, but the effector cells plus the
vaccine or the stem-like cells plus the vaccine gave you
more. So there's an interplay between how much innate
stimulation you get. Having the T cells gives you more type I
interferon. Similar thing for interferon gamma,
and I would note that the stem-like cells gives you more interferon gamma
than the effector-like cells with the vaccine.
And then this is interferon gamma three days later in the spleen, so there's
higher frequencies of interferon gamma as you might expect.So
to show that type I interferon and interferon gamma are important for
protection, we transplanted the tumor, we gave them the ACT with the
stem-like cells, we vaccinated and we showed they're protected, and
then we gave them an antibody against interferon gamma, presumably the
effector that's mediating the killing, and it completely abrogated
protection. As did giving the antibody to interferon
alpha/beta receptor, and if you gave them both, you completely
abrogated protection. So now you have both cytokines
being involved in protection.
Finally, I'll close with some early transcriptomic
analysis to really try to understand how the ACT
is working in the tumor microenvironment.
So this is actually with Visium, so you get everything, 18,000
genes. It's unbiased, so you can try to start to
visualize the in situ mechanisms of tumor control.
And so this just proves,
when you look, and these are
transcriptomes that represent tumor cells with the stem-like cells
alone or following vaccination. So the first thing you can see is there's
dramatic effect on reducing the tumor cells when you
vaccinate. When you look at the immune
cells, and this encompasses all immune cells, you'll see there's a
massive infiltration of immune cells by the vaccination.
So the vaccination has made this into a
well-infiltrated tumor. And I can tell you, those immune cells are
almost mostly macrophages. T cells are dotted
within there, but they're mostly macrophages.
What's notable is when you look at the tumor
transcriptomes, on the left, without the vaccination,
we have transcriptomes that define several different tumor subsets, and one we
call stable tumor and progressive tumor, but it's basically all covered with
progressive tumor. But on the right, you have this massive immune
infiltration, then you have very little tumor.
And those tumor are interferon gamma reactive.
And when you want to look at the pathways of the tumor cells, you can
see that they're led, the highest
frequency of genes in the interferon gamma
reactive tumor pathway are interferon gamma, interferon alpha,
allograft, TNF signaling, and IL-6 and IL-2.
So you have actually made, by the vaccination and
the stem-like cells, you've made the tumor more responsive to killing
through those pathways, which I showed you.
This is just from the Tumor Cell Genome Atlas, and this is a
transcriptional analysis of the most immunogenic tumors, and they have the
same pathways. So even though this is a mouse model, we actually
get data that's really very similar to what's seen from
transcriptional analysis of responsive tumors.
Okay. So
I think just to summarize, I gave you an optimized approach for adoptive
cell therapy. So in vitro, there might be ways
to improve over the culture using a PI3 kinase
inhibitor. We have brand-new data on combining different
inhibitors, and we have data in both mouse and human TILs to
suggest that we can also sustain some level of
stemness in those cell populations.
Then in vivo, I think vaccination works quite well to boost
the CD8 response and remodel the tumor environment.
And then the spatial transcriptomic analysis says that the
vaccine enhances the immune cell infiltrate, which
is critical. And then I think it's interesting
that the vaccine and the stem-like cells alter the tumors
themselves and make them more responsive through a variety of pathways
for killing. And then the other thing, I think, this is probably motherhood
and apple pie, is that the transcriptional analysis of TME
is really critical, and it might be critical prognostically, and it might
be critical to guide therapeutic interventions because T
cells may or may not work depending on the tumor
microenvironment. So I'll close and say all this
work was done
originally by Andrew Shizuka and Jeffrey Lin, and then Faizah
Baharom. That was the first part of the talk, but this was all really led
by Dalton Hermans, who was a phenomenal graduate student who finished
with help from Sloan and Ben. And I'll stop, take
questions.
I think we can do one question
and then move the other questions to the discussion session. Yep.
Hey, Bob. So that was really nice. I'm curious about the PI3 kinase
inhibitor studies. So clearly the cells work better, and
you cure more of the tumors early.
But if you don't, if they're subject to chronic stimulation, are they
more durable, or do they get exhausted and burn out the same as
normal cells? Is there a permanent change in those cells?
Yeah. So that's a good question, John.
And so we don't have data on the durability yet.
And so we're doing that now, but that's a really good question of how
long, how durable they are and how long that will persist.
As you can imagine, the protection starts to wane after
about 30 days. And so,
it's interesting. In the tumor itself, when you look at the transcriptomes of
each of the cells three days later, there's not that much of a
difference,
because they've probably been activated.
And so the stem-like cells, and you might have better insight into this,
really convert quickly.
Yeah.
So I agree with you that the key question would be durability, and
we should do that.
Thanks.
If you could maybe approach Bob afterwards, since we're running behind. Thank you.
Thank you to the organizers and my co-chairs.
So pancreatic ductal adenocarcinoma, PDAC, considered
the immunologically invisible tumor because it
has few neoantigens, few T cells, is
insensitive to checkpoint inhibitors, and typifies the nearly
80% of cancers that similarly have few mutations and
insensitive to checkpoints. PDACs also have very high unmet medical
need. Second deadliest cancer in the United States, 90% of
PDAC patients die with current treatments.
But fascinatingly, 10% in fact survive long-term.
Why? Unknown. So for the past decade, we've been studying these patients with
really two questions in mind: How do they do this, and how could we replicate this?
And what we have learned is that these patients mount natural T cell immunity
to PDAC, characterized by many CD8 T cells in their
primary tumors, that although PDACs have few mutations, in fact
recognize somatic passenger mutated neoantigens that you can
identify a priori based upon their unique immunogenic properties.
Immunity is amplified by innate lymphocytes in the microenvironment
through the formation of tertiary lymphoid structures.
You can also deliver these neoantigens to other PDAC patients with RNA to make
lots of CD8 cells, and these CD8 cells, in fact, have quite exceptional
longevity and function. So over the past decade, we have gone from discovery
to clinical development of two promising new immunotherapies for PDAC, and
today I'm excited to tell you about our work on the first PDAC RNA vaccine.
Now, this story really starts now 10 years ago, when we became interested in, is
there natural immunity in PDAC? And to answer this, we identified
cohorts of short and long-term PDAC survivors and found that
these long-term survivors had primary tumors enriched in many CD8
T cells, leading us to the question, what are the antigens and could they
be neoantigens? Now, the conventional thinking at the time was
cancers with a few mutations would generate a fewer
neoantigens, and this was really an extrapolation from studies in
checkpoint inhibition, where we knew that tumors with more mutations
respond and fewer mutations do not.
So leading to the assumption that neoantigen generation in human cancer was
purely linear. So if you have more mutations,
suited for neoantigen therapy,
fewer mutations, unsuited for neoantigen therapy.
So really to probe this, and as we already had proof of
concept of immunotherapy success in lots of tumors with more
mutations, melanoma, lung cancer, others, we wanted to
understand, could immunotherapy really be possible in cancers with few
mutations? And if we could unlock neoantigen vaccination for pancreatic
cancer, perhaps this could unlock vaccines for many more cancers.
So we developed a new antigen quality model to identify the immunogenic
properties of neoantigens based upon their biophysical characteristics
of non-selfness and selfness. And what we found was tumors
enriched in high quality, but not quantity neoantigens
identified patients with longer survival, introducing
that tumors with very few mutations could harbor neoantigens that are both
clinically relevant and targetable.
And this was supported by the observation that we could find a CD8 T
cells recognizing these high-quality neoantigens in primary tumors
of rare survivors with identical clones persisting in the circulation
for a decade later. So suggesting that these neoantigens could stimulate
long-term immunological memory CD8 T cells
specifically, even if it had very few neoantigens.
And furthermore, when we examined how these primary tumors enriched in
neoantigens evolved out to recurrent tumors, what we found is
selective editing of cancer clones harboring these high quality,
but not other neoantigens. So in sum, more evidence of
natural neoantigen immunity in PDAC.
So what we were finding was natural neoantigen immunity in PDAC
may impact PDAC survival. But as most PDACs in fact
harbored neoantigens, it raised a question, could inducible neoantigen immunity
also impact PDAC survival? And as these neoantigens derive
from patient-specific passenger mutations, we felt the best technology
for rapid custom cancer vaccination really was to use RNA.
So we proposed and convinced colleagues at GenTech and BioNtech that although
they may think PDAC might be the least likely cancer suited for a neoantigen
vaccination or perhaps for any immunotherapy, perhaps it is the
most suited cancer. And this led to this investigator-initiated trial
where we resected primary PDACs in New York, and we shipped the tumors to
colleagues in Germany, who then custom manufacture individualized vaccines for each
patient called autogenous vimeral.
So after surgery, we treat patients with a PL1 blocking antibody,
custom vaccination, chemotherapy, and a vaccine booster.
Now, key question in this trial was, can vaccines generate
neoantigen-specific T cells in a cancer with very few mutations?
Which we realized early required sensitive methods for
detection, because for a single neoantigen administered
as a mutation spanning 27-mer, there is in fact a very
large combinatorial neoepitope HLA space, only a
fraction of which is recognized by an individual TCR leading to clonal
expansion. So trying to monitor the entirety of the immune response from
the epitope HLA side using tetramers is really impractical and
leads to an incomplete answer. So we wanted to understand this from the TCR
side using longitudinal TCR sequencing.
Now, if you just do longitudinal TCR sequencing in the peripheral blood, as
shown here, this is over 20 time points in five years in a
single patient, you can see you get lots of clones in the peripheral blood.
So we developed a new technology called CloneTract to specifically
identify vaccine-induced T cells, as you can see in this
particular green line, an individual T cell clone expanding after
prime and boost. And you can now identify all clones, and
later what we showed was this population contains vaccine
neoantigen-specific T cell clones.
So from a large population of clones, identifying really a
very small fraction that is induced by the vaccine.
So now that you've found these clones, essentially you can track their persistence
over time. And what we find here is that after prime and boost,
these clones have a median estimated lifespan of
7.7 years. So the vaccine-induced CD8 T
cells, in fact, have exceptional longevity despite
post-vaccination chemotherapy.Okay.
So in this trial, what we found was that these vaccines can induce
neoantigen-specific T cells in 50% of unselected
PDAC patients, and these CD8 T cell clones are in fact
substantial in magnitude, recognizing single and multiple
neoantigens. And looking at a follow-up time of 36
months, we found vaccine responders had a median recurrence-free survival
that was not reached compared to non-responders, and this correlation was not
confounded by other factors, neither from host immunologic fitness
differences, because both of these populations generate similar immune
responses to a control RNA vaccination, which is SARS-CoV-2.
Okay. So, so far what we know is that in pancreatic
cancer, these vaccines induce CD8 T cells of high
magnitude, longevity, and function.
And these CD8 T cells are in fact de novo.
This includes a polyclonal, polyfunctional, high avidity population that
over time transitions into memory-like T cells with a
tissue-resident memory-like phenotype.
And immunity correlates with delayed recurrence at three-year follow-up.
Correlation does not imply causation.
We are testing causation in a randomized trial currently.
And finally, resistance appears to occur due to outgrowth of non-vaccine targeted
cancer clones. Okay. So, so far this, but what is in
fact happening right now? So if you look at five years now
post-treatment, you can see that these vaccine-induced T cell clones in fact
continue to persist in the peripheral blood at very high
magnitudes, including up to 1% of all T cells in the
blood. And this, you can see, encompasses several individual T
cell clones, some which persist and others do not, seemingly in
the absence of antigen. So raising the question, could this
perhaps be related to specific features of vaccine neoantigens?
So to answer this, we go back to our neoantigen quality model,
where we estimate immunogenic features of an antigen based upon a similarity
to known antigens and selfness we determine based
upon how the mutated epitope differentially binds either the
MHC or the TCR with respect to the wild type allele.
And of course, for antigen selection for vaccination, we determine or
estimate these parameters a priori, but now we can in
fact directly measure this and ask whether any features correlate with T
cell longevity. So to do this, we turn to an assay that we
developed in vitro to specifically identify neoantigen-specific T
cell clones we call CloneMap. And using this assay, we
identify neoantigen-specific T cell clones in vitro, and
using cloning and epitope mapping, we confirm specificity.
So you can see here for these individual six clones here, they
selectively recognize this 14-mer epitope, but not
epitopes of smaller length. And then for each of these individual T cell
clones, we specifically analyze how these clones
cross-react against a mutated compared to the wild type epitope,
mutated indicated in red, wild type epitope indicated in
blue. And you can see here that some clones cross-react, whereas
other clones do not, demonstrating really a range of a
self-reactivity that extends beyond a different
individual patient to different patients, different HLAs,
as well as to different epitope lengths as well.
So overall, what we find is that these
vaccine-induced T cells in fact bind the mutated epitope
more strongly compared to the wild type epitope.
But interestingly, cross-reactivity of the clone to
the wild type epitope correlates with enhanced longevity in vivo,
suggesting that signaling through the wild type epitope perhaps may
be a factor that allows these T cells to persist in vivo.
Okay, so when we vaccinate, we think we want these vaccines to be able to
make new T cells. Why? Well, if your cancers have very
few mutations to begin with, there's few
T cells there, so you have to make them.
In cancers with more mutations where there are more endogenous T cells,
we believe some fraction of these T cells are likely to be amplified by
checkpoint inhibitors. And as we are co-administering these drugs together in
the clinic, ideally, you may want to have new T cells to avoid
overlap with checkpoint inhibitors and theoretically to broaden
your therapeutic index. Now, how do you know you're making new T cells?
Well, as these preexisting endogenous T cells reside primarily
in tumors and draining lymph nodes, we think peripheral blood analysis really is
insufficient to understand whether these are new or preexisting.
So here we think what really requires clone-by-clone overlap analysis
of vaccine-induced clones in the peripheral blood compared to pre-vaccination
tissues, and we don't think this has been currently done.
So we did this for CD8 T cell clones previously, and we were
interested to now to see whether or not this could also be done for CD4 clones.
Now, I mentioned to you earlier that when we apply clonetrack, we actually don't
see vaccines inducing CD4 clones in this population.
And we hypothesize this perhaps is because we need more sensitive detection
methods. So, we developed a new method called CloneSearch that
essentially identifies groups of different clones in the peripheral blood based
upon their unique longitudinal trajectories in the blood.
And when we apply CloneSearch to our PDAC model, what we find
here is that these vaccines not only induce
CD8 cells but also induce lower magnitude
CD4 T cell clones. These CD4 T cell clones we find in
six of eight of our vaccine responders.
And also, these clones co-appear together with CD8s.
So when the vaccines are making CD8s, they also seem to be
making CD4s.
Okay, but are they new? So to understand this, we track these
clones back to the tissues, specifically the tumors, the normal
and malignant draining lymphatic basins, the adjacent tissues, the
pre-vaccination blood. In total, sampling lots of clone cell
samples and patients. And what we find here is that
97.5 of the CD8 clones and 100%
of the CD4 clones are absent in pre-vaccination
tissues. This is in contrast with 73% of the
PDL-1 induced clones that are present in one or more
tissue compartments. SoPD-L1 largely
re-expanding pre-existing clones.
These vaccines, we believe, are inducing CD8 and CD4 clones
de novo. But do these clones in fact
persist over time? So I mentioned to you earlier that these
CD8 clones have an estimated median lifespan of a year after
prime. That increases dramatically to over a decade after a
single booster dose. Now, what we find with these CD4s is
that after priming, they have an estimated lifespan of less than a
year, and these clones essentially disappear by the time the boost
occurs. However, although they are transient in the peripheral blood,
their presence correlates strongly with longevity of a
CD8 clone. So although they are appearing transiently in the
blood, when they are there, the CD8s appear to be living longer.
Okay. What do these CD4s in fact look like?
So to answer this, we performed longitudinal single-cell TCR
sequencing. And what we find here is that the population of CD4s
across patients and clones resides in two populations here.
Early after vaccination, these CD4s express a proliferative marker
such as Ki67 and very rapidly transition to
a Th1 effector-like phenotype expressing granzyme,
T-bet, and importantly, you can see, not expressing other lineage markers
such as a FoxP3. So we believe these vaccines are in fact
inducing CD4 Th1 effector cells.
I also mentioned to you that their trajectory in the peripheral blood appears to
be transient. So are they dying or are they going perhaps to
other sites? And if so, would they reoccur in the recurrent
tumors? So two of our patients, in fact, have had recurrent PDAC,
and when we look to see whether we can identify these vaccine-induced CD4 clones
in the recurrent tumor using TCR sequencing, what we find here is in
both of these patients, the majority of their vaccine-induced CD4
clones are both present and clonally expanded in the
tumor compared to the peripheral blood.
Okay, so I showed you clinical follow-up at three years.
Now when we look at six-year follow-up, we find here that these vaccine
responders continue to have a median recurrence-free survival that's not reached,
compared to non-responders who have a median recurrence-free survival of a year.
You can see six of eight of these responders remain recurrence-free,
in contrast to one of eight of our non-responders.
And now, this also translates to a difference in overall survival for
these patients. You can see here now, seven of eight of
our responders continue to be alive anywhere between four and a
half to six years after surgery, in contrast to
two of eight of our non-responders who are alive.
And in fact, we believe one of these patients, in fact, is mounting a
subclinical vaccine-induced T-cell response.
So suggesting that inducible vaccine immunity may
also impact survival in PDAC.
Okay, so to summarize, we believe in PDAC, these vaccines,
autogene cevumarán, induces potent immunity to personal
neoantigens by making new CD8 as well as
CD4 T-cells. And we think this is a desirable characteristic
for cancer vaccines. And now at six-year follow-up, we find that
immunity correlates with improved overall survival.
Approximately 90% of our PDAC patients remain alive up to six
years post-treatment. Now, the implication here, we believe, is that
even if a cancer has very few mutations, these mutational byproducts
can empower both potent and composite immunity.
And this is important because potentially expands vaccine
eligibility to potentially many cancers.
And it's exciting that there's many clinical trials in solid tumors ongoing
worldwide to really test these concepts.
So looking ahead now for precision cancer vaccines, now that we have proof
of concept, essentially spanning the mutational continuum at the lowly mutated
space in pancreatic and the highly mutated space in melanoma, perhaps this
indicates that there is a path to test precision vaccines in many more cancers.
However, currently, most centers' patients really cannot access these drugs
because they are deployed in limited lower-risk cancer indications and
centers. So at this very critical inflection point for our field,
we believe it's really an urgent need to unlock access and to really
ignite both innovation and spur progress.
What do we really need for this? Well, what we think we need is a new paradigm of
academia-led end-to-end vaccination.
Now, in the modern era, with advances in AI technology, RNA
manufacturing, GMP technology, we think this is eminently possible.
So you can envision real-time neoantigen selection with ever-improving
models,
on-demand GMP production of RNA vaccines on-site at academic institutions,
state-of-the-art immune monitoring, and paired with an innovation framework really
to iterate and improve over time. So to do this at Sloan
Kettering, a few years ago, we launched the Elan Center for Cancer Vaccines,
where really one of our goals is to develop and build this
discovery to delivery flywheel. So right now we've, for instance,
deployed neoantigen discovery at scale across all of
our clinical samples. This feeds into in-house RNA and lipid
research and development. We have in-house GMP manufacturing for rapid
academic scale, GMP manufacturing for RNA, and this is paired with
clinical vaccination and an expanding suite of homegrown immune monitoring
tools. And we think this can really collaborate and
really add to spurring the innovation and expanding access to these
experimental drugs to patients in trials.
Now, when we were thinking about this expanding access problem, we quickly
realized that this is really an infrastructure problem that cannot be solved by a
single institution. It really requires collaborative efforts across
institutions across the country.
So, we launched the Precision Project at MSK, which
is really an effort to work together with institutions across the
country to build such platforms, expand access
to these drugs in clinical trials for patients, patients not only treated at
MSK, but also elsewhere, with the real focus on high-risk cancers, cancers
which have very few treatments. And it's exciting to now see also the national
efforts sort of developing. So together, we think this can all build
a national cancer vaccine ecosystem, which
overall will spur innovation and expand access to these
drugs to patients in clinical trials.Okay.
So with that, I'd like to just highlight all of the work that I showed you today
was done by Zach Sethna, Charlotte Reich, Martina Milighettti, and Pablo Guasp
in my lab. I'd like to highlight our partners in industry, Ira Mellman,
formerly at Genentech, now at the Parker Institute, Ugur Sahin and Ozlem
Türeci at BioNTech, Ben Greenbaum, my long-term collaborator at MSK,
our clinical team, and patients. Happy to take any questions, and we might just
transition to the discussion so we can have open discussion here. Thank you all.
Remarkable work for the field, Vinod, as you know.
Are you surprised that some of the vaccine responses were pre-existing?
I would expect you selected immunogenic neoantigen, you would have
seen something in the pre-existing tumor tissue.
So what does that say about selecting T cells
for a vaccine-induced response? So you select against them?
Is it detrimental to have pre-existing immunity?
Yeah. I think in
the pre-existing versus de novo question likely has to do
with how immunogenic the tumor is at baseline.
So for instance, the way we've been thinking about this is that cancers with
very few mutations like pancreatic, there are neoantigens, but they do
not, in general, stimulate an
endogenous immune response that is detectable or at least sub-threshold or
supra-threshold. It occurs in a select population in the survivors,
but that's only about 10%. 90% of patients really do not
generate a significant endogenous immune response.
So for such clinical scenarios, you would have to make
new T cells because they are not there to begin with.
In other cancers that are more immunogenic, perhaps exemplified by checkpoint
sensitivity, there are pre-existing cells.
So here you would need vaccines to perhaps do two things, amplify the
pre-existing cells and make new cells.
So, I think this is at least the way we've been thinking about it.
Maybe I'll
give our point of view. It's very
similar to Vinod's, but I guess I would say a few things.
Like in our experience, our ability to detect responses
following vaccination, the dynamics is very rapid.
And to me, that suggests to me that there is probably
pre-existing T cells, but their precursor frequency is
extremely low. We've done a lot of
T cell antigen landscape work, in the
pre-treatment tumors. And we see a lot of T
cells with specificities both for TAAs
and neoantigens, depending on the tumor.
And these are all tumor specific, but you have to remember that they're
there with a growing tumor. So this is a little bit of
tumor archaeology in reverse. We know that there's a
phenomenon of immunodominance. So I think that at some
level, there might be low frequency
precursors that are really with just one or two, we've done this, one or two
stimulations, you can't detect them.
But with the right kind of adjuvant and vaccine
stimulation, you can draw them out and amplify them.
And perhaps they were not natively the immunodominant response, but under
conditions of vaccination, you can really amplify and
expand the army of neoantigen specific T
cells that are there.
It'd be interesting to see with your spatial TCR seq, if you could see where those
clones are located once you go back to the-
Beautiful.
Yep.
Amazing talk. So for the neoantigen that had
very similar EC50 to the wild type,
perhaps the 3D model of MHC and those
neoantigens are very similar to self-peptides.
Do you see less functional capacity for the corresponding CD8 T
cells to those neoantigens specifically, and can we narrow down based
on that,
the efficacy in the patient?
Okay, if I understand correctly, does cross-reactivity to the wild type
epitope impart less desirable
function?
Because I only showed EC50.
It tolerize.
Yeah. So no, we don't actually see that, but it is hard to
perhaps know exactly in vivo their function, because in
ex vivo stimulation, most of these, all of these clones,
they robustly respond when you re-stimulate with antigen.
So whether that really reflects how they're behaving in vivo,
differentially from function perspective, I don't know for sure,
but certainly, their persistence is clearly
different if a clone cross-reacts to the wild type or not, which
is I think interesting because historically, perhaps we've thought you don't want
cross-reactivity to the wild type, but maybe this is not such a bad thing.
And we don't see any toxicity or off-target effects related to this
phenomenon.
So my question goes back to the interferons, so either Bob or Adam.
You showed really nicely the effects, which is not surprising, the interferon on
the innate immune, activation, activation DCs, and then
trafficking into the tumor. But the T cells themselves can express
the interferon alpha receptors. Have you looked at all at whether there's any
direct contribution of the interferon to the T cell intrinsic, either in
the stem-like cell phenomenon or other?
Yeah, that's a good question. We did consider that.
We didn't do what you probably want, where you can do this is you can take
transfer T cells without an interferon receptor to see if there's a
secondary effect.
But I would say we have some more recent data that
suggest in another model that, in fact-The type I
interferon can actually substantially boost the CD8
responses independent of the effects in the
TMA. As you know, interferon, I think and Adam showed it, it activates
dendritic cells, upregulates co-stimulation,
but also interferon IL-15 can drive
CD8s. So we didn't do it in that study, but we have data
from other studies to suggest that it could expand the CD8s as
well.
Thank you.
Hello, my name is Max Coach from Stanford University, and I have a question to the
very compelling data from you, Dr. Balachandran.
So, my question to you is,
did you have on all these neoepitopes that you used across the patients,
were their epitopes were shared by some patients, and
did they respond in a similar way? Or in other words, so
50% of the patients did not respond, and is
there
a reason beyond the actual epitopes, or is it maybe
HLA-driven, or is it something else inherent to the patient?
Yeah.
The question is, why is the immune response only 50% is related to antigen
selection? We don't think it's related to antigen selection.
In fact, this particular intravenous RNA vaccination platform
delivers the RNA through a lipoplex, which has charge modifications on the surface
to selectively deliver the payload to secondary lymphoid organs throughout the body
and the spleen. So the spleen being a critical driver of
the magnitude of the immune response to this particular platform.
So if you splenectomize mice, for instance, the magnitude of this immune response
generated, it reduces by about 50%.
Turns out for pancreatic cancer, we performed two different types of routine
surgeries, one which involves routine splenectomy.
So in fact, most of the non-responders were asplenic at the time of vaccination, so
we think this is most likely reason.
We don't actually think it's related to differences in antigen selection.
Yeah. I have a question for Bob first.
In the PI3 kinase inhibition in vitro, did you look at the
TCR clonal repertoire? Like, is it the change in the certain
clones grow more, or is it really the phenotype that is different?
Give it to me.
Did you get it? No.
Sorry. Can you repeat the question?
Yeah, this question is for Bob. For the in vitro
expansion with the PI3 kinase inhibitor, did you look at the TCR
clonal repertoire to see if it's a different repertoire that is growing, or is this
a phenotype of the T cell different?
So we're actually doing that with human TILs right now.
So we're going to start and
do TCR analysis from fresh tumor tissue, and
then we're going to culture them for a month with and without the PI3 kinase
inhibitor, and then look at the TCRs.
And so we're going to actually do that in humans rather than the mouse studies.
Thank you. And one quick question for Vinod, yeah, you, is what is the role of
CD4 here? You think they can directly
recognize tumor cells and kill them, or they always need the CD8 cells?
I think you showed there are a few patients or one patient had only CD4
response.
So
it's a good question, and we don't know exactly the answer to this, and you could
imagine we can't really perhaps answer this based upon this
data set.
What we can say, I think, is that you do make CD4s.
They do appear to be new, and you can do this in a cancer with very
few mutations, which I think this has not really
been exactly known because most of the other
vaccine platforms have been testing more highly mutated cancers in the setting of
checkpoint. So this is there. Perhaps you might be expanding
preexisting TCRs, not necessarily making new ones.
I will say that previously in the melanoma setting, we did have tetramer
positive,
neoantigen-specific tetramer positive cells that we characterized
transcriptionally, and they are granzyme positive CD4s.
Melanoma has Class II, right? And PDAC-
Class II.
... I don't know, tumors.
Yeah.
Much Class II there on the PDAC tumors.
Okay, so in the interest of time, I think we have to wrap up.
We can, of course, continue the conversations afterwards.
Thank you so much to my fellow speakers and the audience.
It was a great session.
Thank you.
So can we-